oui oui battu fmi une personne qui est
vraiment en charge totalement des
parties internet de la partie twitter de
changer tout ça on part fait sur un peu
tape sur les doigts
sûr qu'avec le titre des salles vides
attendait de chanteur franchement c'est
s'effacer méchant c'est pas très gentil
c'est gratuit mais c'est chien dre un
truc c'est que souvent les services
internet sont décorrélés du service
général konaté elle nous voilà public le
magazine nous on a toujours taper sur
public.fr ici ça n'a rien à voir avec
public la magazine local à l'erc le
magazine sont très sérieux on connaît la
rédactrice en chef qui est super meriem
palomba c'est vrai voilà et public.fr
c'est un torchon
voici.fr c'est un torchon a les mêmes je
sais pas les mêmes au magasin ça fait
moins mal aux vrais maghrébine jeudi au
public à un public voilà et même à
myriam que ça où les gens qui n'ont rien
vous vous êtes un journal voilà qui fait
votre travail
voilà vous avez vous fait pour l'aller
les trucs bien et tout ce qui est sur
internet ça vous portent préjudice
vraiment et me donner un bon exemple
pour les gens comprennent myriam pas
d'embarquer dans l'émission vendredi que
vous produisez tpm des people elle fait
l'émission avec nous et le lendemain
public.fr échec d'audience émission
catastrophique je l'appelle du kent est
gonflé honteux payet tout une femme est
une elle me dit c'est pas moi c'est bip
point fr et je ne peux même pas le faire
enlever alors qu'elle est patronne de la
direction on a gazé chauveau l'île de
manda préfère c'est un alain torchon
voilà je vous lis c'est le meilleur
choix
et alors et au dessus de public.fr
encore plus de la merde c'est voici.fr
c'est de la chasse